what a major major news day I have so
much to tell you about and I'm glad
you're with me today uh so much
happening over the weekend remember
let's start with electr news last week I
told you about Republican Texas elector
Christopher Christopher Supreme who has
decided to vote for someone other than
Donald Trump of course Donald Trump
winning Texas the default the
expectation is that Christopher Supreme
would be casting an electoral vote for
Donald Trump a week from today on
December nineteenth but he said no I am
NOT going to do that and that his
conscience does not allow him to cast a
vote for Donald Trump that much we knew
the news is exactly as I've been telling
you for two weeks based on what a source
of mind told me two weeks ago exactly as
I was told by a second source a
successful democratic operative the news
from krista christopher's a prune based
on an interview he gave over the last
few days is that there are more
Republican electors planning to do the
exact same thing not to vote for Donald
Trump on December nineteenth they have
not gone public of course they have no
requirement to go public in order to go
against their state on December
nineteenth supreme saying quote at this
point there are people who have reached
out to me again it wouldn't be my place
to name who they are I am confident in
saying at this point I don't think I
will be the only one voting for someone
other than Donald Trump who is carrying
a Republican elector seat now who will
these electors vote for it's not clear
last week we had thrown around the idea
of Ohio Governor John Kasich but he has
said not interested don't vote for me
supreme going on to say as electors come
forward and I have had conversations
with other Republican electors in
particular I think we will start
discussing names specifically and see
who meets the test that we could all get
behind uh now here is where it really
starts to get bonkers which is that uh I
came to you telling you that my source
said two weeks ago that there are about
15 of these rogue
Trump electors that will not be voting
for Donald Trump on December nineteenth
we've now learned specifically about one
Christopher sapru NAND we've had the
idea that there are numerous
corroborated not only bicep roon but
also by this other well-placed
Democratic source that I have in
speaking to this source over the weekend
it was revealed that number one that
number of fifteen that i told you about
two weeks ago that has shifted to 20 21
okay that is number one that in and of
itself is huge although again 36 plus
something in addition to 36 would need
to move away from Donald Trump to deny
him the 270 electoral votes that he
needs currently 306 for Trump uh really
305 because we specifically know about
Christopher Supreme here is the
incredible thing I was also told that
individuals believed to be with the
Republican National Committee approached
some of these rogue Republican electors
encouraging them specifically to not
just not vote Trump but to say if you're
not voting Trump cast your vote for
former Massachusetts governor Mitt
Romney known to us as Willard mittens
Romney as you know uh this is absolutely
incredible and what what's amazing about
it is we saw during the lead-up to the
election huge aggressive critiques of uh
of Donald Trump critiques not only up
including personal criticisms but also
involving policy and idea criticisms
from Mitt Romney and what we are being
told here Pat is truly stunning it
particularly when you consider that
former RNC chief rinse Priebus or I
think currently he still is until he
officially starts working for Trump will
be Donald Trump's chief staff it is
stunning what is going on within the
Republican elector world right now yeah
it seems like that number is getting
closer and closer to the 37 that they
would need to block Trump yeah and I I
think a lot of people don't even realize
that the election really hasn't happened
yet until the electors convene on the
first monday after the second Wednesday
in December its or if it's very sketchy
no doubt about
Michael Moore has said hey it's not over
till it's over the the actual election
of Donald Trump hasn't yet happened
Christopher sapru nin this interview he
gave also saying that uh he he started
receiving threats from people when he
announced that he would not indeed be
voting for Donald Trump and I hate to
break it to you people email me they say
David what these electors are
considering doing is a travesty they are
ignoring what is their duty I hate to
break it to you but Hamilton and other
framers made it very clear that electors
must apply their conscience to these
state votes to determine who to
ultimately vote for on that would you
say first Monday after the second
Wednesday type of thing that's be
written that way than that something
like that uh and the anti mandate is
building we have over two million more
votes for Hillary Clinton than for
Donald Trump we have insanely sketchy
situations involving number one uh exit
poll versus election data and and
thirdly we also have the Russian element
now which we will talk about a little
bit later in the show the biggest anti
manded mandate and as long as I can
remember and this is strengthening the
justification to Republican electors for
not voting for Donald Trump and and the
latest news just to put the cherry on
top ten members of the electoral college
is reported by Politico just hours ago
including Nancy Pelosi's daughter
Christine and a former member of
Congress are demanding a briefing from
US intelligence officials on what's
happening involving this investigation
into Trump's ties to Russia we'll talk
more about that later but it's
abundantly clear Pat that there are
Democratic and Republican electors who
want more information before they cast
those ballots a week from today the
popular vote has completely been
undermined into the last five elections
that's what should be doing it that and
that is a concern for many people but
it's almost like there's an
embarrassment of riches in terms of
where you want to focus on the just
total bankruptcy of what we have here in
an incoming president donald trump
administration